what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and i think that thor
love and thunder might have actually
created a major plot hole inside the
marvel cinematic universe now if you
have not seen thor 11 thunder spoiler
alert we are going to be talking about
spoilers for thor love and thunder so
you have been warned now this plot hole
doesn't just revolve around thor love
and thunder it actually revolves around
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game as well and sort of just the entire
mcu this plot hole did not however exist
before thor love and thunder thor love
and thunder created this and it involves
eternity eternity was by far one of the
coolest things about thor love and
thunder i didn't think we were going to
see an actual cosmic entity in the mcu
so soon but we did and we learned a lot
about who eternity actually was in the
mcu eternity was an ancient cosmic being
that grants the wish of the first person
that gets to it and of course in the
movie gore wanted to get to eternity so
he can wish for all the gods to die but
of course ultimately gore does indeed
get to eternity first but instead of
wishing for all the gods to die he
wishes for his daughter to come back and
now thor kind of has a daughter who is
kind of a god this i don't have any
problem with whatsoever i think it's
cool that moving forward thor will have
love and love could even be a part of
the young avengers eventually down the
line however the issue i have here is
with eternity in thor and valkyrie the
second that zeus an omnipotent city
mentions eternity valkyrie and thor both
basically go oh crap they both instantly
know what gore is trying to do he's
trying to go to eternity because
eternity will grant the first person
that reaches it a wish and the wish
could be anything that they want and my
issue here and what i consider the plot
hole is that thor and valkyrie both seem
to know exactly who eternity is and what
eternity does here's my issue if thor
and valkyrie both knew about eternity
and knew what eternity does why did they
not seek eternity after avengers
infinity war where thanos snapped away
half of the universe think about this
for a second in avengers infinity war
thor did not go for the head he drove
stormbreaker through thanos chest he did
this on purpose but this allowed thanos
to snap therefore thor kind of took the
blame on himself that's why he would
eventually go on to become brother but
in avengers in-game the avengers still
go seek thanos and they find him sadly
he has already destroyed all of the
stones and there's no way to get them
back so thor in his rage cuts off his
head and realizes that it's his fault
and there's nothing else he can do to
reverse it however there was something
he could do he could have gone to
eternity and asked eternity to reverse
the snap and bring everybody back at
that point thanos was already dead the
stones were already destroyed he could
have literally asked eternity to just
bring everybody back that was snapped
and thanos wouldn't have come back and
there wouldn't have been a five year gap
this is what i consider to be a big plot
hole at first but now i definitely think
that this is actually marvel studios
setting some things up in the future for
the cosmic entities now obviously of
course people are going to say well it's
the writing eternity wasn't even brought
to the equation until thor love and
thunder unless you believe that star
lord actually did see eternity and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. but
besides that yeah eternity was not
brought into the equation until thor
love and thunder however in the mcu
there has to be some type of continuity
there has to be reason there has to be
logic so what is the real reason that
thor wouldn't have gone to eternity in
avengers in game well like i mentioned
at first i thought this could be a very
big plot hole but now i think it's
actually a huge setup for the future of
the mcu that could have some pretty big
consequences consequences that i would
personally love to see because i believe
that this is a major setup for the next
big avengers end game level movie secret
wars remember kevin feige said that
we're going to start to see all of this
come together soon and see which
direction the mcu was going he also said
that many fans could probably see where
it's going and all of us have seen
secret wars so when thor love and
thunder where gore asks eternity to
bring his daughter love back it does
appear like eternity is no more but is
in fact somewhat inside of love and now
obviously marvel studios changes things
from the comics in the comics eternity
is the actual embodiment of the universe
and eternity basically has unlimited
power however there is an eternity for
each universe so in the multiverse there
are separate eternities one for each
universe unlike the living tribunal that
exists everywhere all at once and in the
comics when thanos had the infinity
gauntlet he actually ranked eternity
right below the living tribunal so as
you can see eternity is a very powerful
entity and eternity typically only shows
up when there is a huge threat to the
universe in the comics this is when
dormammu threatens the entire universe
or thanos gets the infinity gauntlet and
the infinity gems and the heart of the
universe now you may be wondering well
why didn't eternity or any other cosmic
being for that matter step in when
thanos had the infinity gauntlet an
infinity war and end game well since
thanos only threatened half of the
universe this may have been kind of okay
with eternity and he might not have
thought it was a big enough reason to
step in for example in the comics
eternity is summoned by galactus and mr
fantastic in which eternity actually
made reed richard see that galactus was
a part of the natural order of the
universe so that could have been thanos
in the mcu and that could explain why
eternity never stepped in however it
looks like eternity is now gone and that
is very very different and very very bad
this is actually a big part of secret
wars in the comics this is how
incursions are actually able to happen
and why eternity can't step in to stop
our earth combining with other
universe's earths in secret wars
eternity of our earth as well as its
counterparts and other universes were
all eventually annihilated by the
beyonders so when incursions started to
happen eternity and its counterparts
were not there to stop it they were also
not there to stop dr doom this is how dr
doom was able to seize the power of the
beyonders and reshape several different
realities into battle world so as you
can see there are major repercussions to
eternity no longer being around in our
universe but let's say eternity is not
actually gone let's say that he granted
the wish and just simply went away this
has major repercussions as well because
it seemed like eternity was simply
resting he was meditating well now he is
kind of awakened and we know that the
cosmic entities are actually becoming
more and more important in the mcu and
in fact in thor love and thunder we saw
the gateway to other cosmic entities
like death the living tribunal the
watcher those were put there very
intentionally and even in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness doctor
strange and america chavez seemingly go
into a universe where it's a bunch of
living tribunals however i actually
think that this was the living tribunal
watching what doctor strange was doing
seeing if he needed to step in also keep
in mind that all three heads of the
living tribunal have to agree with one
another before they actually step in so
that could be the reason that the living
tribunal is not stepping in with the
incursions yet but as i mentioned it
seems like eternity if he's not gone is
now somewhat awakened and this could be
a bad thing this could actually be a
reason why thor never went to him there
could have been a major side effect to
eternity granting a wish thor is
asgardian he's a god he's over 1500
years old and his father was the
all-powerful odin i'm sure his father
taught him about the cosmic entities and
who eternity was and since neither
valkyrie nor thor thought to go to
eternity right away but knew exactly who
eternity was and were scared of gore
reaching eternity in thor 11 thunder
perhaps they knew there would be major
repercussions of gore asking for a wish
not only would he probably ask for the
gods to be eliminated but it could be a
situation to where if eternity grants
the wish then eternity is gone if
eternity is gone much like in the comics
this could set up god emperor doom to
come to power this could also be how
incursions start to happen and nobody
steps in to intervene now of course
there is the living tribunal but i'm
expecting him to be addressed very soon
as well i believe that marvel studios is
actually building up to the cosmic
entities finally being involved in the
events of the universe and ultimately
the multiverse they are teasing us with
other gods they started in moon night
where they even mentioned that there are
different afterlife realms then they
teased us again in thor love and thunder
with all of the greek gods and zeus and
of course they finally introduced
eternity but there have been other
easter eggs as well like the staff of
the living tribunal and doctor strange
number one and how do you go bigger and
better than avengers in-game well adding
cosmic entities to the equation and then
removing them for all of the chaos and
secret wars to actually happen would be
fantastic and that's what i ultimately
think is happening here in thor love and
thunder i think there's going to be
major repercussions to what happened
with gore and making his wish this would
explain why thor never thought to go to
eternity after avengers infinity war
because if thor knew that he could grant
a wish it would make sense for him to at
least try even if he didn't exactly know
how to get to him it did seem very clear
that thor and valkyrie knew where the
gate was to him at the center of the
universe so even if they didn't know how
to unlock that gate or what the key was
as zeus says they still should have at
least tried giving it a shot but they
didn't eternity was never even mentioned
and while you could view this as one of
marvel's biggest plot holes ever i don't
think that's the case i think it's
actually setting something up for the
future for secret wars but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below do you have your own
theory about this or do you think
something really big is coming really
really soon let me know down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news or theories you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof